das auge isst bekanntlich mit schwierig
bei solch undefinierbaren häppchen die
nach labor schreier weiter im angebot
visuell vertrautes traditionelles
konventionelles nicht ganz denn auf der
futuristisch designten tafel thront
lyoner wurst dass bauern buffet ist rein
vegetarisch doch davon wissen die gäste
die kultur platz zur degustation
eingeladen hat nichts wir sind gespannt
werden sie den braten riechen
die inszenierung der frischgebackenen
künstlerin andreas staudacher
durchschauen lust oder frust jetzt
geht's um die wurst
daher scheint zu funktionieren
mutig unsere gäste wahrten sich auch an
visuell zweifelhaftes
verschimmeltes aber richtig und wonach
schmeckt das irritation andreas
staudacher spezialgebiet im atelier in
bern heck die 26 jährige ihre ideen aus
färbt zum beispiel wurst mit
lebensmittelfarbe ihr ziel verwirrung
stiften
ja mir interessiert frauen im moment los
kriegt also fast ethik zu eco da moment
fing ich spannend und dass ich wieder
ganz der arbeit kommt es immer wieder
vor
darum heißt arbeit oder was ist jetzt
genau ist denn passiert vor allem die
spannenden momente ein moment der
unsicherheit war auch auslöser für ihre
arbeit als kind liebte staudacher
insekten war von ästhetik farben und
formen fasziniert doch vor ein paar
jahren fesselte sie dieses bild
die aufgespießten heuschrecken schrecken
die kunststudentin ab warum der versuch
einer antwort führte zur intensiven
auseinandersetzung mit insekten als
nahrungsmittel ihren ekel hat stau doch
längst überwunden
auch von aden spinnen und skorpionen
macht die experimentierfreudige nicht
halt
das resultat ihre bachelorarbeit das
erste insekten kochbuch der schweiz aus
und das hat es aber überhaupt seit fünf
jahren los auf insekten folgte fleisch
dem heiß diskutierten thema wird mit der
staudacher ihrer masterarbeit
sie recherchierte informierte indem sie
events organisierte auch schlachtungen
den eigenen heißhunger auf fleisch hat
sie gedrosselt ganz ohne gehe es aber
nicht
ich hoffe dass sie nummer knies was
machen mit dem kreis der top 20
seine kreativ und daheim fondue chinoise
gabi nachdem es war mir mit der sie wird
mit mühe machen und neue jahr damit
angefangen dass sie wieder die elf
löcher gestopft haben also ende
schwierig für mich
der gescheiterte versuch machte ihr klar
dass sie nicht zum moralapostel taugt
mit ihren events will die erlebnis
designerin denn auch nicht missionieren
sondern ein bewusstsein schaffen
das farblich komischen sehen dass sie
künstlich geschmacklich perfekt und ich
bin es später zu
den guten szenen über und das seid - mit
geschmack druck internets denn jetzt im
krieg steigen das fazit des abends
top oder flop richtig ist aber erst
worte dann taten